this is sal here and i'm at stanford
medical school with dr andy connolly
hi there sal i'm here with you to
discuss histology today histology and
and forgive me for what is probably a
silly question but but what what is
histology so it'll be the ology study of
but in this case histo means tissues
we're going to be looking up the
cellular um components of organs cool
cool
yeah this this looks neat what is this
so what we're going to be looking at
today is the histology of the colon
and so um for the colon um we often have
um colon specimens come to me in
pathology i'm a pathologist i see right
right and so the colon
like we were saying before is the large
intestine right and so if you have this
piece of large intestine often it's
removed um from the patient because
there's an area of cancer
i see
right or something that might be cancer
they don't so it might be cancer they're
actually pretty good now about doing
colonoscopy looking through the inside
okay so if they know it's cancer that's
what they'll do
they'll often have looked inside um
think it looks like cancer take a little
piece and send it to us beforehand and
then we say something then they remove
the pieces and the reason why they want
to send it to you is even if they know
it's cancer how severe is this cancer
how severe is the cancer um they also
really want to get a good tissue
diagnosis to make sure if they're going
to go remove a pc or colon right that
they really know that it's cancer rather
than it just sort of looks like i see so
it's the definitive proof before they
remove it so then if this is the cancer
that's removed they clearly want to be
able to check the margins
to make sure it's been removed in its
entirety right but often inside of there
we'll find other um pieces of tissue
like here's a might be a policy
right and we say check the margins this
is literally just making sure that
you've covered enough material that
you've gotten all of the cancer in it
that you're not kind of cutting through
the cancer or you've missed some of it
that's right because this is actually
one of the
traditional surgical cures right of cut
it out to cure right for colon cancer
that tends to still be the case right is
you will cut it out to make sure you
cure there are many other kinds of
cancers though which spread so widely
early on right that you don't usually
right yeah yeah makes sense so um the
polyp
can be found also in a piece of colon
removed and a polyp is something that
just sticks up it's just sticking okay
so any any tissue that kind of sticks
out like that yeah it's not necessarily
cancerous no so for instance another
common place you hear about is some
people in the sinuses might have
troubles and they'll have a sinus polyp
those almost always are just
inflamed okay so okay
and then we'll find areas in which it's
just you know the lining is a little bit
roughened and we'll take sections of
those i see and that can happen just
from someone being allergic to food or
just yeah irritations irritation
so just irritation in certain sites so
we're going to have the areas where it's
kind of irritated um some in which
there's a polyp something sticking out
we want to really look at it on the
microscope and then the thing which
would probably they were mainly worried
about right i see very cool so that's
what we're going to cover in the slides
that we look at today so this first one
we're looking at is an example of normal
margin
and so it's from a little piece from the
edge so they actually call the tissue
margin tissue margin i see i see so this
is normal tissue so this is the um the
edge of the specimen or the margin of
the specimen right and they'll say is
the margin clear i see and in this case
this is an example in which yeah the
margin is clear and this is normal
looking colon so this is a cross section
crossing the boundary of the colon so
this area this area up top right here
this is the literally the inside of of
the colon where the i don't know what
the medical term for the the the poop
yeah so yeah so stool yes
right so
yeah that's the stool in the middle
right and then the supportive tissues
are underneath i see this is part this
is essentially part of the you know the
structural tissue of the tube yes that's
right okay all right so let's now drive
around the slide this is a virtual slide
in which we took the
typical glass microscope slide right and
put it in a special machine which took
lots and lots of um photographs of high
power and stitched them all together as
one massive image i see so that then
allows you to zoom in and look around
just to get my my own bearings this this
polyp or this is not even a problem it's
just a ring this is a regular it's a
little bit of a fold a little bit of a
fold but this isn't a polyp so this this
distance right here what would that be
like a centimeter or uh yeah about like
that okay like that'll probably be um if
i had to guess five or six millimeters
based on the size of the centimeter okay
so um now to drive around what you'll
see is you'll begin to see me i'm
driving around with this arrow and these
are the controls for the program for
zooming in and out okay and so if i'm
going to zoom in and out you can see i
click on something and what we'll be
able to do is
look at something more closely and this
gives us the um looking at the and the
word here is mucosa mucosa very similar
to mucus right so the idea of mucosa is
it's the lining that makes the mucus is
the slimy part i see so it's literally
and it looks like what this stuff out
here is oh i'm how do you draw that
that's stuff right there so this stuff
up here is the slimy mucus and so it
keeps um the linings of the insides from
drying out because it's a very hydrated
gel right right but it also means that
things can glide along without abrading
the surface i see so i see so that's
what we have there and then when you
look at it um it has architecture in
which these are glands they're like test
tubes sticking down right and the
purpose is to increase the surface area
and the term gland you hear a lot in
medicine is is this any structure that's
containing fluid and can release the
fluid
what is a gland
so a gland is an epithelial structure so
it's made of cells that are packed
tightly
and the cells have a top on the bottom
right and then they're formed into some
sort of in folding or structure so that
there's a middle and then there's an
outside okay through that structure
thread structure to that structure and
when you say it's on epithelium it's
kind of like the stuff that's facing the
outside world yeah so so the epithelium
is a special class of cells in which
they are facing the outside world once
again tightly packed right and there's
always the top there's a bottom eye that
are different and even though to a lay
person
this area right here might not seem like
the outside world it seems like it's
inside of you we're kind of like big
donuts that's right and and the um
colonoscopist proves that it's connected
to the
outside world exactly right a
colonoscopy yeah they can come right in
here they can come right in right so
that is still the outside world at great
pain and expense so that's still the
outside world and so um this is the
architecture where you have infoldings
to increase the surface area and it's
creating this mucus
but let me look um
at the highest power here which is to
then look at these cells i mess around
this is a this is cool so yeah when we
look at these cells there's there are
two main kinds of cells there's this one
here
which is the goblet cell goblet cell
right and so this is and it's it's this
whole it's not just this this white part
it's it's the part that goes all the way
down there yeah all right here let me
have that pen let me have that here are
the experts and so here it is it's got a
top like that and then you see this wine
glass okay so that wine
it's literally shaped like a goblet yeah
i was certain i was i was i was circling
the wrong handle no you got the wrong
nucleus they're wrong
that's where some other cups on yeah
someplace else
uh what's next to it though are there
these these thin cells here which do not
have all the um mucus inside of them
where are those and these guys here are
just these tall ones oh i see you okay
and you only see the nucleus the dark
part is yeah so that's why you don't see
it so the white part is just all this
mucus inside of this right so what this
is is this is actually um it's mucus is
um the term for either the the the
overall structure or the the material
that's elaborated up here i see um
chemically it's something called musin
is it's almost like you know the runners
who eat that goo
where it's just a lot of sugar holding a
lot of water i see it just be bad
branding if they call it mucus in a bag
yeah no no
yeah exactly
so they stick with goo we'll call it but
but this one has lots of sugars and
takes on a lot of water and that's abuse
and that's released and it forms this
surface right here to let the stuff flow
by what the other cell does though is
the other main thing in addition to
letting things flow through
is to absorb water i see so the idea is
you don't want to release the two liters
of fluid that you have around every one
of your wheels right you want to get a
lot of that flow that's the main use of
the of the large intestines that is it's
it's
a consolidation process out of the stool
that's right another stool so you're
going to absorb a lot of the water and
see um you're going to be doing it
through these cells so just to be clear
so the i'll do this in blue so the the
mucin would come out here and then the
water would be absorbed by these things
that don't have that mucin parts would
be absorbed right there or right over
actually maybe like right over there
yeah that's nice that's exactly right i
see so two main functions of the colon
are right there with those two cells so
now um going back to the and actually
just just to get a perspective of where
we are i understand that the whole thing
is about half a centimeter wide
you know these
what's our scale like how big are one of
these cells or okay so so um our
favorite scale bar here is actually to
um
look for blood vessels
and in the blood vessel is these are red
blood cells so that one right there
is seven micrometers in diameter seven
micrometers and a micrometer is a
millionth of a meter or a thousandth of
a millimeter that's right so it would be
seven thousandths of a millimeter so
let's round off to ten yeah so about a
hundredth of a millimeter that's right
so you put 100 of these next to each
other you get a millimeter so millimeter
would be bigger than our entire screen
right here that's right so you'd see
that with these glands a millimeter
would be about this kind of span which
we're saying up here is about like that
so that's why i was thinking this thing
might be from here to here about seven
millimeters across right something like
that but that's uh red blood cells are
found in almost every microscopic field
and they're always seven micrometers wow
so that's that's useful yep so um so you
got that going for you so so when
looking here
um you've got um this is very well
uh formed um you can see here these
tubular glands just a hint over here is
because they're like test tubes
sometimes they're not going straight up
and down and they look a little at an
angle like they'd be going oh so but
they actually are reaching the surface
we just don't see it based on the way it
was cut so so this one right over here
for example this it was just cut at an
angle so it looks like it's embedded
there and it's two dimensional but in
three dimensional we would see an actual
tube dropping out and and uh just to go
back with the microscopy um we're seeing
this because it's only four microns
thick so four micrometers thick and
we're sending light through this tissue
right so that's why you can get
something which the cross section
doesn't show you the three dimensions
right right very much a two dimensional
fascinating fascinating
cool so so and so this is what a healthy
a a healthy uh i guess would you a
margin tissue would look like yeah this
is a healthy colon and so you would um
thankfully say on the proximal margin
which is up towards more towards the
mouth that's clear you take another
section like this from the distal margin
more towards the end and you say that's
clear so that means they've removed it
all and when you said proximal margin is
close to the mouth you're not saying
you're saying the mouth of that cut that
yeah yeah yeah so if this is if if that
was the tube you're not saying close to
the mouth of the person no
no no not at all you're saying mouth of
the of the that section of tubing that's
right so we would say the proximal
distal margins are clear if they look
like this very good excellent